a summer of record-breaking heat is
drying up rivers across europe as around
half of the continent faces an
unprecedented drought in the uk the
driest july in over 80 years has largely
evaporated the source of the river
thames italy's longest waterway the
river po has sunk to record lows
threatening food production and here in
germany low water levels in the rhine
are threatening to make boat passage
impossible
cutting off a major shipping route
scientists have warned that climate
change means extreme heat and drought
will be more common in the future
desolate dry and desperate for rainfall
this is the current state of the river
rhine in western germany
normally the water level of the rhine
here in cologne is about three meters at
the moment it's just 85 centimeters at
other points along the river the water
is already below 40 centimeters this
boat restaurant is supposed to float but
the low water level means it's currently
on a lean
of course we're hoping that it rains in
switzerland and in southern parts of
germany then we'll get the water that we
need to be a boat restaurant again and
float as usual
still guests are happy to come and see
the unusual view
the water level of the run is certainly
worrying at the moment compared to its
usual level
i'm very worried about the drought in
the low water i can see the shipping is
suffering fish are suffering and the
environment is suffering
of ferries transport tourists and
commuters across the rhine but nicholas
teal service could grind to a halt in a
matter of days he's already thinking
about long-term solutions
we'll have to adapt adapt the ships
accordingly and if necessary we'll have
to use new ships that have a lower draft
but there will be solutions the ryan
could be deepened for example that's
already under debate
for bigger freight ships however the
economic consequences could be more
extreme
the rhine is used to transport masses of
industrial raw materials including coal
but many barges are being loaded at just
one quarter capacity to keep them higher
in the water which means dividing up
cargo among more boats
just four years after a historic drought
in the region the low water levels are
also ramming home the impacts of climate
change
after the drought in 2018 we asked
ourselves whether this was a great
outlier whether this would only occur
once every 200 years but now we have
this situation again four years later in
a similar form it seems that these
conditions will occur more frequently in
future
many people here fear that water levels
will sink even further in the coming
week which could lead to even more
disruption of traffic here on the rhine
weather forecasts point to some
potential rain but that won't ease the
situation overnight
for more i'm joined by andrea torretti
he is a scientist who specializes in
climate change at the european drought
observatory welcome to dw sir um
considering current conditions and
forecasts is there a chance the drought
in europe can get even worse
uh good morning by looking at the
short-term forecast we see that finally
some rain will come next week
but by looking at the seasonal forecast
for the next three months there is still
a risk of drier than usual conditions so
it's a bit early to say but
clearly
there is still some risk
so what happens on the ground is at the
mercy of what comes from the sky
it's an overused phrase i suppose but do
the current conditions represent the new
normal for europeans
uh not yet but they might become the new
the new norm if
we do nothing in terms of effectively
mitigating
climate change through cutting the
emission
uh basically this kind of events could
become the norm already
in the worst projections mid-century
meaning that they could occur almost
every year
i'm curious is this drought as
historically bad as it actually seems or
are we just paying closer attention to
all things climate change
it seems to be actually the worst on on
record we haven't completed the analysis
because the event is still ongoing but
uh by looking at the worst event the one
of 2018 i was the worst looking back at
the
list of the last 500 years
this year event seems really to be much
worse than the 2018 in terms of special
extent in terms of persistence
as well as in terms of severity
scientists are
mostly proud pragmatists as you well
know but are you worried by what you see
around you
of course i am because
you see the impacts of these uh these
events what is really worrying me a lot
is uh the
uh the occurrence of concurrent events
all around the world because the drought
in europe is only one drought we
shouldn't forget the uh the other ones
for instance affecting east africa with
the
incredible human uh humanitarian crisis
there
the persistent multi-annual drought in
south america affecting la plata basin
so that this is what is really worrying
me
the most
well noted um
climate scientist andrea terretti many
thanks
thank you
you